i'm joe grunfest i'm a former  commissioner of the united states  securities and exchange commission i'm  also a professor here at stanford law  school where i'm a professor of law and  business and also run the rock center on  corporate governance  in addition bill sharpe and i several  years ago founded financial engines  which became the world's largest robo  advisor we currently manage about 175  billion  so the intersection of technology and  securities regulation has always been a  large part of my area of interest  given that background and everything  that's happening here in silicon valley  it's easy to understand how bitcoin  blockchain and all issues related to  crypto pretty much have percolated to  the fore in terms of the scholarship  that i'm doing conversations here in the  valley and and you know research and  speaking around a wide range of topics